brand new numbers and the economy just
in initial jobless claims slightly
higher than expected 860 000 americans
filing for unemployment benefits last
week
peter navarro an assistant to the
president and director of the office of
trade and manufacturing policy joins us
now
peter so what are those what does that
new number mean for
our economic recovery are we climbing
our way out of this
uh there's no question we're climbing
our way out of it and
the way i like to look at it we'll let
folks like larry kudlow talk about the
big macro what i
what i do for the president is work on
the micro stuff and today
uh he's going to wisconsin tomorrow
minnesota
and at the micro level i'm going to
explain to you why we're going to do so
well
in both of those states if you look for
example at wisconsin
you start in oshkosh the president did a
huge defense budget increase
we got great one of the state-of-the-art
combat
vehicle plants there if you go up to
marinette near the green bay area
the shipyard there is booming when it
was was all but dead under the obama
biden administration
you go over to wausau that's really
interesting it's close
close to the duluth area and what's
happening over in minnesota
is there's this natural resource
renaissance that's come about in logging
but particularly because of the steel
and aluminum tariffs the whole iron
range up there
is booming they make these things called
the taconite pellets that then
come down and get on the docks of boats
in duluth
and then they off they go on the great
lakes to the steel mills around the
midwest
so if you look at all this economic
activity
uh that's the result of the kind of the
focus on manufacturing
focus on the workers i think that's
what's going to really lift things up
and and by the way
there's big ten football as well people
are happy and go for land and badger
land today
but the the fact is he is hitting uh the
campaign trail and he is going to
wisconsin
obviously he sees some work to be done
there obviously a narrow margin that he
did
unexpectedly win that state in 2016.
he's heading to
mosinee in marathon county today it's a
county he
handily carried back in 2016. why there
peter
well look this is the most active
president in terms of traveling why
there will be there today
it'll be somewhere else in the state in
another week this president it's really
interesting to watch his travel schedule
compared to to the joe biden not express
this president is the hardest working
president you've ever seen i mean think
about the travel schedule
wisconsin today minnesota tomorrow north
carolina and then
next monday it's going to be ohio and on
so we're we're hitting it hard i think
everybody understands that that the
swing states are going to be
really what determines this election but
they play right into donald
j trump's strength because it's all
about being a blue-collar president
and being the republican party being the
party of the working class the residents
of that state as well as
throughout the country wondering what
happens as far as
a relief bill and stimulus checks
you have the president now talking about
an even larger stimulus package his
priorities been the twelve hundred
dollar stimulus checks
here is a tweet from the president on
dems and bailout
money he says democrats only want
bailout money for blue states that are
doing badly
they don't care about the people never
did
mark meadows was on this network this
morning detailing what he says the
president wants
listen what number did he tell you he
wants
well he was certainly willing to embrace
the 1.5 trillion dollar
number that was put out in the last day
or so
it really depends on what the priorities
are so add to that peter what does the
president want
so tr trusted meadows here it's a
negotiation we do that behind closed
doors
unlike the democrats who like to do it
in the rotunda
the one thing i can tell you sandra and
this is not news uh
but it should be repeated uh nancy
pelosi's
the problem here uh there's a lot of
people in her party who want to deal
because they
understand the pain and suffering
of the people in this country whether
it's not having a job or whether forcing
uh eviction or foreclosure uh i'm not
sure what's going on with
with pelosi but there is definitely a
deal to be done whether it's 1.5 or
something
else but look what's it gonna take to
get this done this week
well i think uh talking on shows like
this and just raising awareness so that
the
american public puts pressure on capitol
hill it's
nancy pelosi appears to be the obstacle
here there's a lot of people in her
party
who want her to move off that dime uh
unfortunately and this is the sad truth
i think she's gambling that if the
economy is bad
president trump loses and she gains
power in that kind of calculus if
there's
any truth to that at all that has no
place in this great country
she's obviously pushed back on that
notion as it has been floated out there
she pushed back on all sorts of emotions
pressure from members of her own party
to your point peter navarro always good
to have you thanks for being here this
morning great to talk senator